all right Diana
Leana where were you from originally
where'd you grow up Montana home in
Missoula yeah tell me about your
childhood you grew up with both your
parents no I was actually abused until
and I lived with my mom and dad for a
little bit on and off and foster care
and then about seven I was put into
permanent foster care for three years I
live next to a guy who finally became
the governor Montana and then moved to
Missoula to a foster home tells 20 at
the age of 10 in half so you left your
biological parents at what age it was
about officially about five or six that
I was finally couldn't live with the man
but what was going on
my dad was abusive and my mom was in and
out of the be acute mental hospital from
the abuse so he was abusing your mom as
well mmm-hmm and my sister in your
sister and how was your childhood in
general um it was rough you bounced
around I couldn't be who was inside
being trans in Montana places would have
probably got me killed and I just didn't
really have a happy child
and then you look home at it would age
19 I left the foster family actually yet
said not 20 but it was 19 and I tried
worked it on and off
up until 2006 when I finally got my cell
security couldn't really hold a job that
much because of my mental illness and I
was homeless quite a bit I actually got
into a really good apartment before I
came here and gave that up for my
transition so you made a transition from
male to female
at what age I I was 40 and a half years
old when I came out oh I held you know
44 okay so this is fairly recent yeah so
you lived all your life mostly as a man
kind of been hiding in hiding yeah yeah
and in Montana you have two right yeah
you don't except that when I was in the
Treasury there was a famous case in
Wyoming where a gay guy our gay kid
killed yeah I remember that and so you
know I couldn't but I knew I couldn't
come out and I struggled with it even
when I came out with 2016 because it's
still not tolerated mud sir but you know
I mean the choice just start trying to
be happy you know no matter what
everybody else sings and then at what
point did you come to LA I came here
back in two years ago
February or March of 2018
I wasn't expecting quite so much hate
being an LGBT state I came here because
it's one of the states that does many
many for finishing the transition and
I've been homeless ever since but I'm
getting closer to get my house so I mean
in terms of transition we're using
medical medically medically what did you
desert I'm wanting to do surgeries but I
can't have it until I have my own place
oh I see so then it's a few different
surgeries in Washington there there are
bottom surgery the Adam's apple and
possibly voice was it right
I know a lot of the ladies take hormones
too
yeah I've been on those since January
27th of 2017 and you're happier as a
female yeah that's great where do you
live now
um I'm not a shelter off of Central
Avenue so you're in Skid Row or no I'm
almost I'm I'm a few blocks past Bern
and oh so you're not really
nearby Skid Row no I come here and hang
out at the Women's Center and visit some
of my friends but after some hassle at
midnight mission I've been trying to
stay out of Skid Row area did you used
to be in I had a bad hate crime happened
on pittance and Julian would have a week
before Christmas a guy because I was
turns gender hit me with the metal
folding chair several times
broke my cane on me hit me with fists
and I am still suffering a concussion
from it it so used to live on the street
here yeah I've had tons of hate crime
I've been beat up several times almost
burnt alive right outside of the Women's
Center where I slept on the street
somebody put you it say you I'm sorry
they doused my sleeping bag with I woke
up a few seconds later with the zipper
tampered with and it soaked with lighter
fluid so many had chased them off oh my
god now it was like September 2nd of
2018 well so you're a shelter right now
that you feel safer in yeah and one of
the most dangerous parts of LA for trans
is free and the Skid Row yeah I'm sure
there's lots of violent crime here but
there's lots of resources and that's
where most of us come
do your friends I have a few friends at
the Downtown Women's Center but anytime
when I just got out of a relationship
with my ex and any time I made friends I
don't have that many because my ex made
me cut ties with anybody I make friends
with so what do you do for money now um
I'm on Social Security disability but
it's just not enough to live off of
really are there any other options for
you to make money with my physical
disabilities and stuff it's hard there's
a few things I can do but you know I
just haven't gotten into doing it what -
what were your disabilities he's
mentioned I have a real bad knee bad
ankles bad balance and severe bad back I
fractured at one time been in multiple
accidents along with degenerative discs
bulging discs and narrowing of the spine
then you also mentioned mental yes I
have bipolar one ADHD manic depression
and the manic depression is worst of it
it makes it hard to hold a job I'm sure
what do you wish was different about
your childhood that may have made your
life easier
um I just wish that there was more love
and that back back when I was you know I
wished it was like today when trans are
able to come out to their parents and
live the life that they want to live and
instead of being forced to live if
somebody they don't feel they are what
do you think the most misunderstood part
of being transgender is
like you must get all kinds of different
reactions violent the most the most
wrong thinking of being transgender is
that it's a mental problem over in
Europe they actually have studies that
pre HRT and everything else so you still
only be able to do it by autopsy and
they weren't sure whether the hormones
change the brain or not but there's
different site areas of the the brain
and that a trans individual matches
perfectly for a female like me would
match perfectly for female and mekt
ranzz males match male especially in
grey and white area of the brain for
matter wise there's all sorts of studies
done like that oxford and european
countries that are proven that and you
know I just wish that a lot of this
would get out more you know show and
also their studies were they asked
five-year-old kids questions they about
how they feel is a gender and the trans
individual answer exactly the way a
female would answer the questions
there's no right or wrong lean answer
the questions and the turns man answer
the boys answer the same way a boy would
answer and you know and you know that
kind of shows that it's more in the
brain than it
is anything else and the most common
misconception is that that more mentally
ill or you know that we're confused or
we don't know what what we are and you
know and if it would get out there more
on the studies you know the hate might
lessen yeah it would be nice right do
you have any family that you stay in
touch with my mom and my sister my mom
my sister by facebook and my mom by
phone and this is your stepmom my
biological oh your biological mom I have
a relationship with their even those in
foster care
I see and then I have old foster mom
that and the one that I live next to the
guy the ex governor of Montana that I
stand touch with too as well but they're
all the way back to Montana yeah except
well Lilliana thank you so much for
talking to me and good luck with
everything and getting housing oh thank
you thank you
you